[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public 90
minutes de débats et de reportage pour
donner du sens à l'actualité et voici le
sommaire de ceux 30 janvier avec deux
thèmes d'actu aujourd'hui d'abord la
réforme des retraites entre le Parlement
et la rue le texte est examiné depuis ce
matin en commission des affaires
sociales à l'Assemblée il sera de
nouveau critiqué dans la rue demain la
puissance des manifestations la cohésion
de la majorité présidentielle des
hésitations de députés LR les
concessions acceptables pour le
gouvernement de cette équation à
plusieurs inconnus dépend l'avenir de la
loi et peut-être aussi le dessin du
second quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron et
puis dans 45 minutes nous plongerons
dans l'engrenage de la violence en
Israël depuis jeudi les attentats des
Palestiniens répondent aux raies
d'Israélien dans les territoires occupés
est-ce le prélude d'une nouvelle
Intifada 61% des Palestiniens 65% des
Juifs israéliens le pense l'arrivée au
pouvoir de l'extrême droite aux côtés du
Premier ministre
la démocratie israélienne en danger nous
répondrons à ces questions tout à
l'heure mais d'abord donc un trio qui
montre de la fermeté Elisabeth borne
Bruno Le Maire Gérald Darmanin ils ont
durci le temps à la veille d'une
nouvelle journée d'action contre la
retraite à 64 ans Aurélien Romano la
première ministre affiche clairement ses
limites à la veille de la semaine
d'examen du texte non ça n'est plus
négociable la retraite à 64 ans et
l'accélération de la réforme Touraine
c'est de compromis que nous avons
proposé et c'est je vous le dis
nécessaire pour assurer l'équilibre du
système une fermeté qui irrite les
oppositions notamment chez certains
républicains je répète ce que j'ai dit
depuis des mois de manière constante et
mes conditions n'ont pas changé une
réforme des retraites oui une réforme
des retraites injustes non et pour moi
non plus ce n'est pas négociable la chef
du groupe rassemblement national Marine
Le Pen a elle déclaré que après un
ministre ne devrait pas trop s'avancer
la bataille parlementaire sera aussi
celle des amendements les députés de la
pas eux seuls on en déposé 6000 ce qui
fait dire au ministre de l'Intérieur que
la nuque ne cherche qu'à bordélisait le
pays là encore déclaration contre
déclaration c'est le chef de la France
insoumise qui lui aurait brutaliser le
pays puisque vous l'avez dit 70 % des
Français sont opposés à cette réforme
des retraites et donc il veut passer en
force il veut brutaliser tout le monde
donc la meilleure réponse ça sera des
millions de personnes dans la rue mardi
des millions de personnes dans la rue
mardi cela reste encore à démontrer en
revanche les prévisions de trafic sont
tombées comme la précédente journée de
mobilisation celle de mardi s'annonce
très suivi le ministre des Transports
avance lui-même que la journée sera
compliquée et conseil à ceux qui le
peuvent de télétravailler je vous
présente tout de suite mes invités
béatrie Giblin bonsoir bon bienvenue
vous êtes géographe directrice de la
revue Hérodote Mathieu souker bonsoir
bienvenue consultant essayiste co-auteur
avec Damien Fleurot de 2022 la flambée
populiste chez plomb Pierre-Adrien
Bartoli bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
directeur des études politiques à
l'institut Harris Interactive Mathieu
croissanto bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à
vous batterie Ghlin est-ce que vous
pensez que la majorité présidentielle
elle est fragile tiens à la veille de
cette deuxième journée d'action et de
manifestation
pas si fragiles que ça je pense que pour
le moment on est en train de montrer ses
muscles dans toutes les dans tous les
cas et que si on commence à dire mais
oui on va la voter tout va aller très
bien
non il est important encore on a
peut-être encore quelques marches de
manœuvre je pense par exemple aux femmes
des choses peut-être dans ces domaines
là si on commence à dire on vous suivra
comme un seul homme à ce moment-là ça
peut permettre au gouvernement de redire
sa position et de dire bon de toute
façon on l'a fera passer donc c'est pas
grave donc là on est quand même dans un
jeu parce que un peu de chat et de
souris on va dire et que on peut penser
que infini la vautrons moi c'est ma
conviction et qui ne finit ça passera ça
pas des traces négatives
et c'est pas évident du tout mais je
pense que ça passera je pense que il y
aura assez de députés l'air pour la
voter et je pense que le modèle lavotra
parce qu'on va céder on va négocier
encore à la marche pas sur les 64 ans
mais on négociera encore à la marche
Mathieu Souka est-ce que la forte
mobilisation du 19 janvier j'anticipe
pas sur celle de de demain est-ce
qu'elle a surpris certains membres du
gouvernement est-ce qu'il s'attendait à
ça alors manifestement et en tout état
de cause elle a confirmé effectivement
qu'il y avait une vie opposition dans le
pays les leaders syndicaux eux-mêmes se
sont dit surpris en fait par l'ampleur
de la mobilisation plus de gens
qu'attendus et surtout des gens dans des
secteurs qui n'avaient plus l'habitude
de bouger alors je ne sais pas si la
majorité est fragilisée je note quand
même que il se passe quelque chose de
relativement inédite à dire que les
doutes qui ont saisi l'opinion depuis
quelques semaines semble saisir une
partie des troupes politiques et on voit
que la bataille de l'opinion a été pour
partie perdue parce que on dépit de la
pédagogie qui est faite les Français ne
sont pas du tout convaincus que cette
réforme était il pense qu'elle est
nécessaire si je regarde un peu les
enquêtes d'opinion mais qu'elle n'est
pas urgentes qu'elle n'est pas juste et
3 qu'elle n'est pas efficace puisque
tout le monde a compris quand il était
on allait devoir y revenir dans assez
peu de temps donc une réforme qui n'est
pas urgente qui n'est pas juste et qui
n'est pas efficace on se demande
effectivement mais c'est quoi l'opinion
chaque fois l'opinion qui réagit comme
ça face à une réforme des retraites
alors encore une fois il y a une forme
de maturité de l'opinion quand même sur
ce sujet là puisque ça fait des années
et des années que l'opinion en
particulier pour ce qui est de la
situation démographique je pense que
l'évolution du système est nécessaire
ensuite se pose la question de savoir
évidemment quelle évolution du système
et sur qui repose l'effort mais du coup
pour partie le débat est raté parce que
voilà on sur ces trois items encore une
fois la majorité a plutôt perdu la
bataille de l'opinion et alors on va
analyser évidemment la communication du
gouvernement la stratégie des DLR mais
c'est c'est intéressant pire parce que
là vous publiez à l'instant cette fin
d'après-midi un nouveau sondage Harris
interactif pour AEF info qui est assez
édifiant déjà on va commencer par les
sympathisants Renaissance puisqu'on
essaye d'évaluer la solidité on va dire
de la majorité présidentielle qu'est-ce
que ça donne oui mais effectivement
c'est ça qui est le plus intéressant au
final dans les chiffres d'ensemble et on
les connaît tous au final on a à peu
près deux tiers des Français qui sont
opposés à cette réforme ou un tiers qui
est favorable mais on peut se dire que
derrière cette répartition on
retrouverait peut-être cette espèce de
tripartition de la vie politique
aujourd'hui et que le tiers qui serait
derrière Emmanuel Macron est derrière la
majorité serait tout favorable il y
avait versement les autres serait
opposés mais c'est pas ce qu'on voit
c'est pas ce qu'on voit et ça fragilise
justement une partie du gouvernement
parce qu'il peut pas totalement compter
ni sur ses troupes à lui ni sur les
troupes
automatiquement ou naturellement allié
très concrètement quand on regarde les
sympathisants Renaissance aujourd'hui
seulement entre guillemets 71% se disent
favorable à la réforme alors oui c'est
majoritaire évidemment on pourrait
sentir très bien on a dépassé la barre
des 50% mais ça veut dire que le
gouvernement le président de la
République est au sens l'art de la
majorité ne fait pas le plein chez elle
pire quand on prend les électeurs enfin
vous les sympathisants des républicains
qui sur le fond de la réforme devrait
quand même être grosso modo d'accord
avec ce qui est porté aujourd'hui
au-delà des jeux politiques on en a 59 %
qui aujourd'hui se disent favorable à
cette réforme donc là non plus on est
très loin de faire le plein et quand on
fait pas le plein chez soi et qu'on a
des critiques à l'extérieur la situation
en termes d'opinion et à cet endroit
peut-être vous demander tout à l'heure
l'évolution Béatrice gimlin il y a quand
même un argument qui est assez peu
utilisé par le gouvernement on parle de
la voilà des arguments qui portent
est-ce que la bataille de l'opinion est
perdue ou pas c'est c'est l'argent qui
est dépensé par l'État pour équilibrer
le système
en tout cas depuis longtemps
le déficit pas si grave que ça à terme
ça sera 12 13 ou 14 milliards comme on
est habitué à raisonner maintenant en
centaines de milliards bon
c'est pas grand chose au fond mais il y
a quelque chose qu'on je trouve qu'on ne
dit pas qui me semble important c'est
quand même déjà rien que pour que ça
puisse fonctionner combien l'état
j'allais dire ah bon de ce système là
pour des raisons de solidarité elles
sont parfaitement légitimes pour des
raisons de compétitivité le cice ou
l'absence de charge sur les bas salaires
bah il faut bien que ce soit qu'on
pensait aussi pour équilibrer des
régimes spéciaux je dis pas qu'il doit
pas y avoir de régime spéciaux mais je
veux dire la SNCF en 1950 c'est 500 000
cheminots la SNCF aujourd'hui c'est un
peu plus de 100.000 bon alors il y en a
des qui sont morts bien évidemment mais
ça veut dire que vous avez un nombre de
retraités chez les cheminots surtout qui
partent quand même à 55 ans qui est très
important donc il est important de
financer cela donc
simplement pour que ça puisse
fonctionner et qu'on puisse verser des
retraites légitimes c'est pas ça que je
remets en cause simplement c'est un peu
plus de 100 milliards tous les ans donc
les 14 milliards qu'on annonce et en
plus de ces 100 milliards qui sont déjà
donnés donc ça veut dire que c'est 100
milliards il faut bien les emprunter
pour une part parce que c'est pas vrai
on n'a pas tendance que ça et que si on
a des taux qui vont un peu à la hausse à
la note elle va être un peu lourdèche je
comprends pas qu'on ne l'explique pas
alors excusez-moi mais je finis juste
là-dessus tout le monde comprend quand
même qu'on vit plus vieux tout le monde
comprend qu'il y a moins d'actifs à
terme pour pouvoir payer les retraites
tout le monde trouve que il faut
augmenter les retraites de ceux qui ont
les retraites les plus les plus faibles
alors comment on fait on dit ah ben
toute façon les vieux on les met dehors
donc de toute façon c'est pas la peine
d'allonger la durée de cotisation mais
un raisonnement quand même un peu court
si vous voulez j'ai un peu l'impression
qu'on veut quand même tout et son
contraire en même temps voilà moi je les
prends pas la retraite forcément
j'essaye ça un moment de regarder un
certain nombre de choses c'est un
argument qui a Édouard Philippe pourrait
éventuellement porter on l'entend pas
toujours aux abonnés des 67 ans
enfin il y a plus d'un an alors dans
l'eau fossive de de communication
gouvernementale il y avait notamment le
ministre de l'Intérieur dans dans Le
Parisien ce dimanche qui défendait la
valeur travail le travail c'est pas une
maladie on va voir la la une de nos
confrères du Parisien je vais le citer
il y a ceux qui défendent la négation du
travail ce qui pense qu'il faut
travailler de moins en moins et défendre
le droit à la paresse comme à
labrousseau Monsieur Mélenchon et ses
amis défendent d'une société gauchiste
bobo celle d'une société sans travail
sans effort il n'est pas une maladie
c'est au contraire une belle valeur
Matthieu si on analyse au-delà de
l'interview de du ministre de
l'Intérieur l'exécutif fait décidément
les yeux doux au Républicain oui entre
nous c'est il s'agit plus d'appel du
pied mais carrément d'appel de phare on
rappelle brièvement l'équation sur les
retraites les républicains enfin sur les
retraites sans la républicains le
gouvernement n'est rien ou presque parce
que la loi peut passer on le sait au pas
de charge avec le 49-3 si besoin mais ce
serait cher payé très cher payé hein
pour Élisabeth borne qui plus est pour
faire passer un texte que les
républicains s'ils avaient un peu
d'honnêteté intellectuel devrait voter
dès demain tant leur projet ressemble à
celui qui les appelait de leur vœu
depuis des années oui voilà la politique
c'est comme les antibiotiques c'est pas
automatique et républicain se faisant
prier l'exécutif multiplie les signaux
vous l'avez dit à l'égard des élus LR
comme de leur électorat et pour leur
parler ce week-end alors que le texte
arrive à l'Assemblée le gouvernement a
donc envoyé deux de ses poids lourds qui
parlent le LR comme personne et pour
cause parce qu'ils en viennent Bruno Le
Maire et Gérald Darmanin alors dans le
Journal du dimanche le ministre de
l'Économie a trouvé des accents de perle
à rigueur pour promettre de passer
toutes les dépenses publiques au peigne
fin de les réduire de façon
significative de dire que le quoi qu'il
en coûte c'était fini on aurait dit du
2017 dans Le Parisien son collègue de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin à lui
célébrer vous y faisait allusion la
France du travail de l'effort du mérite
en opposition à cette gauche de la
paresse qui l'accuse de vouloir border
le pays c'est presque du Sarkozy dans le
texte avec la bordalisation qui pourrait
même évoquer la chenille si on remonte
plus loin dans l'histoire est-ce que ça
fonctionne cette opération sélection
mais pas très bien il faut le
reconnaître ou en tout cas ça fonctionne
mieux dans l'électorax chez les élus
vous en avez parlé le sondage monde qui
a quand même une majorité de des
sympathisants LR même s'ils sont pas
extrêmement nombreux mais c'est quand
même une majorité qui est favorable à la
réforme mais les élus eux continuent de
faire la fine bouche c'est pourtant pas
faute de les avoir traités d'une
certaine façon parce que Elisabeth borne
les avait reçu en délégation vous
souvenez le 12 janvier dernier après
leur avoir lâché le report de l'âge
légal à 64 et non pas 65 ans elle leur
avait même cédé la revalorisation de des
des de toutes les petites retraites
actuelles et futures les bases d'un
accord sont posées se féliciter alors
eriksiottil patron du parti accompagné
de Bruno Retailleau le patron des sén et
de son homologue de l'Assemblée Olivier
Marleix qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé pas
très courageux ou ni très cohérent ou
les deux plusieurs députés ont repris
une certaine façon leur indépendance
alors on n'a pas encore chiffré exact on
parle de dizaine plus d'une quinzaine
puis de 20 ils sont en fait inquiets des
retours qu'ils ont dans leur
circonscriptions et certains menaces de
s'abstenir voire de s'opposer au texte
si le gouvernement ne résout pas le
problème par exemple des gens qui ont
commencé à travailler à 20 ans et vous
savez qui vont devoir cotiser 44 et non
pas 43 ans comme tout le monde ou si on
ne décale pas la date de l'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme aussi on ne fait
pas une clause revoyure un peu plus
proche certains Antoine même des accents
che guevaraz pour dénoncer le report de
l'âge légal à 64 ans ce qui est encore
pas de sel quand on se souvient de tout
ce qui proposait la vérité en fait c'est
que beaucoup d'entre eux préfèrent
laisser le gouvernement se débrouiller
tout seul avec cette patate chaude
d'autres ne souhaitent pas dans un
calcul un peu plus stratégique voire
diluer leur identité et se voir
repousser au rôle de de enfin réduire au
rôle de supplétif d'autres encore n'ont
aucune envie de faire des cadeaux à
cette exécutif qui n'a cessé de vouloir
les éparpiller façon puzz alors on
récolte ce que l'on sème argut-il
oubliant un peu vite que si Macron dans
l'aventure perd des voix qui lui importe
et des alliés de circonstances eux
risquent les républicains d'y laisser
une part de leur crédibilité alors si
merci Mathieu si on analyse cette
bataille de l'opinion auprès des LR donc
vous nous avez donné une première partie
de réponse moi ce que j'aimerais savoir
c'est comment ça évolue c'est à dire que
est-ce que effectivement même en
concomitant avec les déclarations de des
différents chefs de du parti LR au Sénat
ou à l'Assemblée est-ce que les
sympathisants ADR étaient plus nombreux
à soutenir cette réforme à l'époque et
et est-ce que ça se réduit un peu en
peau de chagrin oui c'est ce qui se
passe et grosso modo on a dans cette
nouvelle vague qui vient de sortir
d'enquête quatre points de soutien en
moins à la réforme et ces quatre points
ils viennent pas de nulle part ils
sortent forcément de la bouche de
certains des sympathisants
un peu de gauche ils viennent aussi de
droite et c'est là que c'est intéressant
c'est sympathisant LR 59% qui
soutiennent la réforme donc on est plus
d'un sur deux mais néanmoins pas une
écrasante majorité ils étaient 14 points
de plus il y a quelques jours quand on
faisait la même enquête même question
donc on se rend compte qu'on fait d'un
côté une forme d'appel du pied ou appel
de phare effectivement assez élu mais
que ça ne passe pas le message ne
n'arrive pas jusqu'aux électeurs qui eux
sont détournent de plus en plus et puis
surtout ce qu'on dit pas à ce stade
c'est à force de faire des appels du
pied à ces électeurs de droite les
électeurs du centre gauche décrochent et
c'est ce qui se passe sur la réforme
c'est à dire qu'on a une part non
négligeable de sympathiser en PS et
Europe Écologie Les Verts qui étaient
pas totalement opposé à la réforme qui
était ouvert à une forme de dialogue qui
avait pas une approche dogmatique qu'il
a commence à dire mais on ne donne un
rapport de force assez classique et on
va être contre ce qui est porté
aujourd'hui mais pire que ça ces
électeurs socialistes et écologistes qui
étaient une part du soutien dont on
parle assez peu d'ailleurs d'Emmanuel
Macron dans les enquêtes de confiance
quand on dit la cote de confiance côte
de popularité s'il était proche de 50%
ces derniers mois c'était aussi parce
qu'une part de cette gauche le soutenait
indirectement assez faiblement mais le
soutenait quand même et ben dans les
dernières enquêtes qu'on vient de sortir
7 ce soutient de la confiance à Emmanuel
Macron qui du coup dépasse le cadre de
la réforme des retraites qui venait de
la gauche se réduit de plus en plus et
on est passé en dessous de cette barre
de flottaison à 50% ben si j'ai bien
c'est vrai que je reprends une une des
phrases de Mathieu qui a des accents Che
Guevara et c'est vrai que parfois les on
a l'impression que certains élus ou
députés LR sont carrément à contre
emploi quand en cherchant à adoucir le
plus possible le texte
incontestablement mais le rapport à leur
circonscription et sans doute
essentielle vous savez ce qu'il y a
quand même le plus surpris le nombre
bien sûr mais c'est surtout la
géographie de ces manifestations c'est
ça qui a été là ça a été les
manifestations des villes moyennes et
petites c'est à dire on a rejoué les
gilets jaunes il y a rancœur des gilets
jaunes bon qui s'était calmé ils avaient
essayé de relancer le mouvement mais non
ça ça marchait pas elle a pu s'exprimer
là pour partie pour partie puis c'est
quand même des endroits où dans ces
villes la fonction publique joue un rôle
extrêmement important que ce soit les
hôpitaux que ce soit les enseignants ils
représentent si vous voulez parfois à
certains endroits c'est jusqu'à 20% de
la population active donc ils se sentent
évidemment très concerné par la par la
par la réforme des retraites donc ils
ont pu être nombreux elle est manifestée
bref des chiffres à guérets qu'on
surpris à foi des endroits où on s'y
attendait pas du tout y compris parfois
des endroits encore beaucoup plus petit
que ça et c'est ça qui a beaucoup
surpris maintenant c'est important quand
même de regarder la composition si vous
voulez active de cette population et moi
je pense que c'est quand même beaucoup
une population
de fonctionnaires moi ce qui me frappe
toujours horrible originaire du Nord
c'est la faiblesse manifestation dans le
nord-est de la France alors que on se
trouve dans des endroits qui sont en
grande difficulté où on a quand même des
taux de pauvreté qui sont élevés alors
on me dit c'est le désespoir il croit
plus en rien donc ils y vont plus moi ça
m'interroge si vous voulez comme par
exemple dans cette région là on peut pas
dire qu'on ait eu un vote Mélenchon qui
était important à la présidentielle non
il arrive très souvent loin derrière et
compris Marine Le Pen et moi je trouve
qu'il serait intéressant qu'on
s'interroge un peu sur la stratégie de
Marine Le Pen dans cette affaire-là
est-ce que je la trouve très habile je
le regrette presque mais c'est comme ça
c'est à dire qu'elle se met vraiment sur
le chemin de crête elle sait qu'elle
peut pas si elle va dans les
manifestations les gens du RN vont se
faire laminer donc ils vont pas donc
elle vivait pas elle joue l'opposition
responsable c'est nécessaire donc je
vais prendre ce qui devrait surpris et
moi je crains fort qu'elle engrange dans
cette séance là cette séquence là des
appuis
qu'elle n'avait pas encore c'est-à-dire
qu'elle se crédibilise et je trouve ça
assez préoccupant et je trouve que la
gauche qui clament je pense au PS
objectif 60 ans 40 ans d'annulité ils
savent parfaitement que c'est impossible
ils savent parfaitement que c'est pipeau
tout comme Mélenchon d'ailleurs qui le
sait tout autant ils ont fait l'inverse
et je vais venir faire croire à des gens
qu'on va revenir à 60 ans et que ça fera
40 ans d'adulité c'est du mensonge
politique pur et c'est un mépris des
citoyens alors on y reviendra à la
gauche le PS la nuque mais effectivement
en faisant je suis d'accord avec vous un
focus sur le rassemblement national et
Marine Le Pen je vous posez un peu la
même question à tous les deux d'abord
Mathieu souker est-ce que finalement
c'est moi ce que j'entends ce que vous
dites qui est qui était passionnant
c'est une sorte de peut-être de trésor
de guerre dans l'opinion qu'elle est en
train de de secret de capitaliser avec
avec cette réforme est-ce que vous
diriez ça alors oui sachant qu'il y a un
bouger en réalité quand même sur la
question des retraites de tous les
partis on est parti des LR effectivement
Emmanuel Macron en 2017 a présenté une
réforme des retraites qui était une
réforme des retraites CFDT donc le
contenu avait été dilué avec la CFDT
cette fois-ci une nouvelle réforme des
retraites au cœur de son programme mais
qu'une réforme LR qui est exactement la
réforme que par ailleurs proposait
Valérie Pécresse quelques mois après
seulement donc les LR font un pas de
côté ne la soutiennent plus et demande
même à l'adoucir on considant qu'elle
est trop brutale donc il y a un bouger
DLR se bouger DLR n'est pas anodin quand
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 se fait élire
sur son slogan travailler plus pour
gagner plus l'immense majorité des
Français se retrouvent derrière ce
slogan et donc sa victoire elle se
retrouve en particulier là-dessus 15 ans
après l'opinion n'est plus du tout la
même sûr que le 15 au travail n'est plus
le même 15 ans après c'est même
l'inverse en fait vous avez une majorité
de Français qui se disent prête à
travailler moins quitte à gagner moins
et donc de ce point de vue de bouger des
LR fait écho bouger de l'opinion très
bon papier dans chez nos confrères de
des échos ce matin sur les les
conducteurs les chauffeurs de bus
chauffeurs de car conducteurs qui pour
beaucoup ont quitter leur job pour des
boulots moins bien rémunérés mais vous
avez aussi un bouger alors effectivement
du PS en réalité le PS devrait défendre
le principe Touraine non pas du tout on
reparle de la retraite à 60 ans de façon
en fait assez peu originale et je dirais
même que le PS on revient à ces
positions de 1981 c'est quand même
étrange parce qu'en 40 ans le monde du
travail a quand même changé et je ne
sais pas dans quelle mesure tout le
monde a 60 ans tout le monde a la
retraite à 60 ans c'est de la justice
sociale je n'en suis pas sûr mais le RN
aussi a bougé en l'été parce que pendant
très longtemps quand même le programme
politique et économique du RN c'était
moins d'impôts moins de dépenses
publiques et évidemment moins
d'immigration aujourd'hui précisément
sur la retraite c'est aussi très
différent c'est-à-dire que Marine Le Pen
a fait une révolution conceptuelle et je
n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que le
président Macron est pour parti
aujourd'hui dans une impasse politique
s'il passe s'il passe sa réforme en
force il pardon s'il ne passe pas sa
réforme il s'affaiblit politiquement son
image de réformateur est durablement
écornée s'il passe sa réforme en force
je pense que il ne se renforce pas il
renforce Marine Le Pen car ce renforcera
dans le pays en fait l'idée que la
politique menée est injuste et qu'en
particulier elle se fait sur le dos
alors des petites gens est-ce que ça se
confirme dans vos dans vos enquêtes
est-ce que Marine Le Pen engrange d'une
certaine façon c'est un peu trivial mais
c'est ça quoi
si on prend un peu de un peu de recul
quand on regarde par exemple l'enquête
on vient de parler on a 23% des
sympathisants du rassemblement national
qui se disent favorable à la réforme
donc en gros une très grande majorité
qui opposée c'est clair et c'est à peu
près le même niveau chez les LFI de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
pour donner un ordre de grandeur donc là
c'est clair après je pense qu'il faut
pas qu'on se trompe sur un aspect
l'opposition à la réforme de retraite à
mon avis c'est pas seulement une
opposition individuelle c'est pas des
gens qui font leur calcul et qui disent
mince je vais bosser x trimestre de plus
donc je suis contre c'est une question
collective question de modèle social
c'est dans quel modèle social dans
quelle société j'ai envie de vivre
demain or le clivage qui est en train de
d'être construit notamment par Marine Le
Pen autour de cette réforme des
retraites c'est la France de la
protection qu'elle porte et dont elle
veut être le faire de lance contre cette
France un peu à utiliser le terme
disruptive lors du premier canal
d'Emmanuel Macron en tout cas qui qui va
de l'avant et qui fait sauter certains
carcans à peu traditionnels qui sera
incarné par le Président de la
République et en faisant ça elle cherche
notamment à regrouper autour d'elle des
pans politiques parce qu'on appelle nous
des segments d'opinion qui vont bien
au-delà de son public traditionnel des
lecteurs de la droite de la droite
grosso modo autour cette idée de modèle
social français à protéger et dont elle
serait le garant et ce qui est paradoxal
c'est que ça ne c'est pas la gauche qui
entonne ça c'est avec la gauche j'essaie
de réveiller une forme de lutte des
classes à l'ancienne avec des slogans
anciens des réflexes anciens à côté des
syndicats alors que Marine Le Pen agrège
c'est vrai des électorats ne faisait pas
partie du du front du front de classe on
disait autrefois
déshérités qui sont des retraités et
même des retraités dans certaines
enquêtes sont majoritairement contre la
réforme alors qu'ils ne sont pas
impactés et certains sont sensibles
c'est vrai à ce discours de protection
qui est pas très précis non plus parce
que le projet de réforme des retraites
de Marine Le Pen personne pourrait dire
vraiment bien compris bien sûr et avec
un discours de sur l'immigration que
elle et ses lieutenants même plus besoin
de quasiment de porter parce qu'il est
totalement intégré
par l'opinion vous parliez de la gauche
Mathieu visez vous l'avez cité par
Gérald Darmanin dans toujours dans cette
interview aux Parisiens aujourd'hui en
France la nuque ne cherche qu'à
bordéliser le pays la présidente on va
voir peut-être cette citation et ensuite
la on va écouter la présidente du groupe
LFI à l'Assemblée elle lui a répondu cet
après-midi je vous propose d'écouter
Mathilde panot
donc plus ce gouvernement parle et on
voit qu'ils ont plus beaucoup
d'arguments vu la manière dont Monsieur
Darmanin notamment insulte l'opposition
de ce pays plus je pense que la
manifestation de mardi sera une grande
réussite et on sent une certaine
fébrilité y compris dans le début de nos
travaux de la part de la majorité et
quand on voit cette opposition qui
grandit à chaque fois je comprends qu'il
soit fébrile en quelques éléments d'info
en cette fin l'après-midi de lundi sur
le effectivement la mobilisation prévue
demain trafic très perturbé alors là ça
concerne les Franciliens RATP un petit
peu moins que le 19 janvier nous dit la
RATP mais enfin ça sera quand même très
compliqué de circuler 50% de grévistes
annoncé par les syndicats dans
l'éducation nationale de la maternelle
au lycée nous disent les syndicats de
l'éducation nationale Béatrice Gibelin
pour reprendre la formule de du ministre
de l'Intérieur est-ce que la nuque ne
cherche qu'à bordéliser le pays non mais
je pense que il a repris ce qu'avait dit
si je me trompe pas Laurent Berger
Laurent Berger avait parlé à un moment
il fallait pas
le bordel ou un truc comme ça je
pense que ça fait écho indirectement à
ça il faut être un coin dans l'unité
syndicale peut-être
sans doute en tout cas de mon point de
vue je pense quand même ministre n'a pas
assez exprimé de cette phase de cette
façon-là voilà il y a une forme de
vulgarité qui ne grandit pas le le
personnage bon même si il paraît que ça
trouve des échos bon positif donc la
changer un petit peu parce qu'elle a
diminué son nombre d'amendements
puisqu'on était parti sur des flux
combien plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'amendements bon
voilà là on est assimilé
déposés mais il y a quand même une
contradiction qui est de dire on en veut
pas parce que on veut pas des 64 ans
donc on ne veut pas de cette retraite et
puis par ailleurs nous mettre des
amendements moi j'y vois une certaine
des amendements ça veut dire que ça peut
quand même s'améliorer bon
leur première stratégie qui était une
stratégie j'allais dire d'obstruction
mais ça ils sont rendus compte que les
Français ils aimaient pas et que il
trouve que au Parlement
justement c'est un endroit où on peut
débattre et peut-être où on peut
améliorer les affaires alors si on dit
systématiquement non alors il y a plus
il y a plus de départ et d'une certaine
façon il y a pas de démocratie donc ils
sont rendus compte je crois mon point de
vue de ça puis peut-être qu'ils se
disent il faut qu'on fasse quand même un
peu attention parce que si jamais ça
passe pas
et si jamais on passe aux 49.3 et que
nous on a essayé de jouer le jeu et
d'amander mais peut-être qu'on saura un
peu en balance et que ça sera pas très
clair on aura participé au jeu et puis
pour finir on perdra la manche d'une
certaine façon donc je pense qu'il y a
aussi tout un jeu un peu compliqué de
leur part sachant quand même que sur les
6000 amendements tout amendement qui
serait des dépenses supplémentaires
tombent automatiquement puisque le
budget est déjà voté donc ça veut dire
qu'il peut peut-être en rester pas tant
que ça donc moi je trouve leur attitude
assez
c'est curieuse d'une certaine façon et
je trouve que
est-ce que est-ce que c'est pas d'une
certaine façon une attitude du RN qui se
veut responsable qui joue le jeu du
débat parlementaire on était démocrates
ou la nuit après comme des noms
démocrates bon voilà donc il y a
deux attitudes là sur deux extrêmes qui
est quand même intéressantes à
étudier et je pense que le dernier point
qui est vraiment important demain c'est
que la manifestation se passe bien s'il
y a beaucoup de jeunes
lycéens étudiant un peu remonté qui est
en vie un peu dans des coudre et tout et
que ça se passe mal
ça ça sera délicat à gérer il faut
vraiment que les syndicats tiennent ça
et que ce soit absolument impeccable ça
c'est toujours on va on va revenir à la
nuque et notamment en PS on a un
reportage tourné à Marseille ce weekend
avec Quentin calmé on va le voir dans
une minute mais je veux bien quand même
peut-être je vais vous donner la porte
là dessus sur qu'est-ce qui peut faire
basculer une opinion publique si on
regarde un peu dans le rétroviseur de
des précédents mouvements similaires et
ce qu'effectivement question du blocage
ou de la violence ça ça peut faire
basculer une opinion
ce qu'on voit dans le quand on regarde
les historiques des différents réseaux
sociaux qu'il y a eu c'est que la
l'opinion est relativement stable au
final on entre dans le mouvement avec
une opinion et elle évolue rarement
radicalement alors les neutres parfois
ça grège plutôt du côté des pour plutôt
du côté des comptes mais ça fait
rarement la bascule totale et c'est pour
ça que la force en tient moins au
mouvement social en tant que tel qu'on
rapporte de force y compris
institutionnelle d'ailleurs là on aura
une question de calendrier pour le vote
de la loi qui qui peut jouer il y a un
point qui est effectivement peut jouer
plus que les autres c'est cette question
des violences on l'a vu dernièrement
lors du mouvement des gilets jaunes qui
est le enfin la quintessence de cette de
cette évolution de l'opinion
parmi les premiers actes on avait vu sur
les murs enfin un mur à Dijon cette
cette formule sans casseurs pas de 20h
qui montrait que une part de ces
personnes qui manifestaient avaient
besoin de ces violences pour avoir la
visibilité et en fait ça produit l'effet
inverse dans l'opinion c'est-à-dire
juste une tout un pan de la population
qui était d'accord avec l'origine de la
colère qui était exprimée c'était dit
oui je suis d'accord avec le fond mais
plus avec la forme et là on avait vu une
forme de basculement ras-le-bol partiel
parce que le niveau de soutien restait
quand même très très élevé tout au long
du mouvement justement sur cette
question de la violence qui était pas
cautionné Mathieu Souka c'est peut-être
dû en parler des LR c'est peut-être
justement du côté de l'électorat ou des
sympathisants LR que une
radicalisation durcissement voilà je
sais pas quel terme employé du mouvement
pourrait pourrait peser finalement on
était à ça entre 50 et 60% de de vie
favorable face à cette réforme alors
d'où la sortie de Gérald Darmanin sur le
bordel mais elle est quand même étrange
sa sortie on voit bien politiquement son
origine mais elle est quand même étrange
elle intervient après précisément une
première mobilisation
ultramative et parfaite c'est-à-dire que
2 millions de personnes dans la rue
partout en France sont le moindre
débordements et ça organisé par la dupez
absolument mais soutenu par la nuit
je voulais dire qu'on voyait le
savoir-faire des syndicats regardez par
les syndicats
on a fait presque 2 millions mais dans
des petites villes qui sont pas des
lieux de violence 80
000 on a fait beaucoup beaucoup plus à
Paris hein
c'est pas du bordel c'est pas la chiant
lisse c'est la démocratie et on voit
aujourd'hui suffisamment d'image de
l'Iran ou de la Russie pour se dire
réjouissons-nous en fait d'avoir la
possibilité la liberté en fait de
manifester et effectivement même au
Parlement cette citation elle intervient
quand même au moment où y compris la
nupesse y compris à la fuite en fait
revoit sa stratégie parlementaire parce
que elle est fille a effectivement tenue
compte des enquêtes d'opinion ou les
Français sont en fait relativement à
l'aise avec l'équilibre des forces au
Parlement la majorité des Français alors
la majorité des Français et nostalgique
de la cohabitation mais la majorité des
français est aujourd'hui très à l'aise
avec l'idée que il n'y a qu'une majorité
relative au Parlement et que cette
majorité relative elle nécessite en fait
de la co-construction parlementaire et
c'est très intéressant parce que y
compris dans l'opinion de gauche la
moitié de l'opinion de gauche ne se
retrouvent pas dans la posture en fait
de d'opposition frontale d'opposition
radicale des députés de gauche au
Parlement alors justement ça pose la
question de la place du Parti socialiste
de sa stratégie notamment au sein de la
nuque la nuque est-elle également
affaiblie par les divisions au sein du
Parti socialiste ça va être le thème de
notre dernier chapitre dans ce débat une
synthèse vous le savez a finalement été
trouvée ce week-end à Marseille quand un
calmer Flora sauvage et Adrien pas était
au palais du Prado
c'est l'image du week-end avec la
réélection d'Olivier Faure le PS se
montre uni et entend tourner la page
après deux semaines de psychodrame nous
pouvons passer des jours à débattre de
l'orientation et ensuite passer des
nuits à recoller la vaisselle cassée
d'où la commission de rigolement
de ce fait les journalistes viennent
régulièrement assister à notre
enterrement et à chaque fois
heureusement nous les décevons pour
sortir de la crise au sein du PS la
direction a dû donner des gages à
Nicolas mayor Rossignol chef de fil des
opposants à la ligne d'Olivier fort le
maire de Rouen intègre la direction du
parti avec le titre de premier
secrétaire délégué
un rassemblement nous avons porté ce
rassemblement et nous nous retrouvons au
cœur regardez le nouveau dispositif
regardez la nouvelle gouvernance
refondation n'existait pas il y a quatre
mois en quatre mois nous nous retrouvons
au cœur de la gauche et au cœur du Parti
socialiste c'est une très très bonne
nouvelle les socialistes ont donc réussi
à afficher une image de cohésion à
Marseille ce week-end mais le débat en
interne ferrage notamment sur la place
du PS au sein de la nuque ce qui a
changé dans ce congrès par le vote des
militants sur les textes orientations
c'est que nous sommes toujours
extrêmement rassemblement de la gauche
c'est indispensable mais que nous nous
le plaçons plus dans le cadre d'une
domination durable de LFI et de
Mélenchon qui se cache derrière le mot
Nuxe le point de clivage le plus
important c'est par rapport à la mupes
ou nonupes je pense que en tout cas la
décision de la nuit pèse de d'être dans
la nupesse et renforcé à partir du
moment où 80 % de nos conseils
nationales et favorable à être dans la
nups les prochains jours seront donc
critiques avec cette question dans tous
les esprits quels seront les séquelles
de la guerre interne des dernières
semaines
Mathieu Souka avec ses 41000 adhérents à
jour de cotisations le Parti socialiste
n'est pas encore mort pour reprendre
l'image Olivier fort il est quand même
très malade est-ce que vous diriez
agonisant en tout cas il a donné une
image absolument calamiteuse lui-même il
y avait ce dimanche alors oui parce que
les sourires sont de façade je veux dire
c'est compliqué de de faire l'accord
avec ce non pas avec lesquels on n'était
pas d'accord la semaine d'avant mais
qu'on a accusé surtout de dire que les
deux camps quand même se sont accusés de
tricherie l'exercice démocratique a été
calamiteux organisé un congrès pour
trancher une ligne politique ou une
ligne tactique c'est tout à fait
important et c'est même pas
problématique ça crée évidemment de la
division mais derrière la division il y
a du débat de fond et la question posée
de l'alliance de l'union de la gauche de
l'alliance au sein de la nuque ou pas en
fait et tout sauf une question
secondaire c'est une question tout à
fait intéressante le problème c'est
qu'elle a été pour partie éclipsée par
le spectacle en fait du fonctionnement
démocratique du Parti socialiste qui
renvoie aux pratiques d'antan hors
précisément une des critiques de laupes
de LFI faite par une partie du Parti
socialiste et de dire Jean-Luc Mélenchon
a un rapport compliqué à la démocratie
et les filles n'est pas un mouvement
démocratique quelle est l'image donnée
par le Parti socialiste cette semaine
encore une fois on peut à la fin faire
un accord sur le fond ou sur la tactique
avec des gens avec lesquels on ne
partageait on ne partageait pas tout la
semaine précédente mais après s'être
accusé de tricherie de hold-up et de vol
et de fraude ça paraît quand même
extrêmement compliqué oui les les
américains ils ont une expression ils
quand un scrutin est trop serré
peut-être qu'il fallait faire revoter
alors je dis pas que c'était la solution
miraculeuse en tout cas ça dit bien que
pour la question tactique de fond le
Parti socialiste est totalement divisé
la moitié du Parti socialiste est
effectivement pour l'union de la gauche
l'autre moitié moins pourtant
historiquement le PS a toujours été pour
l'union de la gauche tu as du programme
PS qui menait à la gauche pluriel Parti
socialiste était pour l'union de la
gauche parce que précisément il était le
leader de cette union de la gauche alors
au moment du programme commun c'était un
peu plus tangent mais on voit bien que
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que
l'union de la gauche ne se fait plus
sous la houlette ou la domination du
Parti social autour de l'union de la
gauche c'est un petit PS par Mitterrand
face à un gros communiste et le rapport
de force est inversé d'aucun espère que
ça pourra se reproduire aujourd'hui des
institutions actuelles la réponse est
non pour l'instant et non à mon avis un
moyen terme parce que les soirées que
l'image est déplorable parce que les
Mathieu alors il faut aussi se dire la
vérité ça a toujours triché c'est celui
qui gagnait était celui qui triché le
mieux c'est comme ça dans les
fédérations la plupart des congrès ont
été émaillés ça ça s'arrangeait se
souvient on se souvient duel Martine
aubryon royal qui était absolument
de la confrontation que des gens de
Bourré mais enfin c'était le seul parti
où il y a des fédérations entières qui
qui votaient comme un seul homme voilà
enfin c'était toujours toujours le sous
l'emprise du du soupçon après le
problème c'est que la la ce qu'on a vu à
Marseille ce weekend ne règle rien la
question du leadership est à peine réglé
oui en façade sur les papiers en tête
Olivier Faure sera devant mais juste à
côté de lui il y a son principal rival
Nicolas Maillard rossignol qui avec qui
lequel il ne partage pas du tout la même
tactique la question tactique n'a pas
été tranchée on le voit bien non plus
faut-il faire accord ou non avec laupes
la question va se poser pour les
européennes même si les socialistes
semblent plutôt en majoritaires pour
partir en solo mais voilà et sur le fond
on en ça revient à la question de la
retraite pourquoi la nups change de
stratégie sur la retraite il y a deux
effets qui me permet d'ajouter à ce que
vous avez jeudi très justement tout à
l'heure il y a quand même un effet qui
est la procédure législative choisie par
le gouvernement au pas de charge qui
réduit considérablement le temps des
débats et donc si vous faites de
l'obstruction mais ça ne sert absolument
à rien oui parce que vous ne pouvez pas
faire durer le plaisir le plaisir on est
on ne regarde pas de près les articles
importants bien sûr que l'autre et
l'autre argument c'est est-ce que vous
avez entendu un socialiste défendent la
proposition de la nupette sur la
retraite est-ce que vous avez entendu un
écologiste sur la défense certains le
font pas d'autres on sait bien qu'ils ne
sont pas d'accord sur leur proposition
phare qui est le fameux retour au 60 ans
avec 40 minutes si on reste sur le Parti
socialiste d'être régime là il y a
effectivement Mathieu vient d'y faire
allusion les les élections européennes
l'année prochaine ça va être une sorte
de juge ça peut être un test intéressant
parce que à mon point de vue tel où on
en est aujourd'hui ils vont pas partir
sur une discommune lupesse ça je n'y
crois pas les écolos ne veulent pas ça a
été dit très clairement par Marine
Tondelier et le PS voilà alors seulement
c'est quand même dans pas longtemps
est-ce que le PS a refait un peu une
santé c'est présentera-t-il quelque
chose de crédible aura-t-il travaillé
aura-t-il une tête de lit ce qui pourra
entraîner de façon à avoir un score qui
soit aux alentours on va dire de 10 %
qui voudrait dire que oui il est en mode
marche parce que derrière ça il va se
poser assez rapidement le problème de la
succession d'Emmanuel Macron qui peut
pas se représenter et vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure ça serait justement
qu'une partie de ceux qui se centrent
gauche commençait à avoir envie de
s'éloigner de retourner vers le PS si on
a un PS mais avec une logique j'allais
dire de vouloir exercer vraiment le
pouvoir donc d'être très
réformateur et pas dans une logique
révolutionnaire à la Mélenchon il est
très possible qu'une partie de cette
électorat qui est allée vers Renaissance
et Macron rebascule sur un PS
social-démocrate et là on peut avoir
effectivement une j'allais dire
réamorcer
une possibilité d'avoir un parti
social-démocrate mais pour ça il faut
que le PS travail et des idées
avance et soit pas seulement
dans cette version peut-être des même si
elles sont petites des victoires
électorales parce que oui mais il a
quand même une base régionale d'accord
mais il a quand même encore une base
régionale et il tient quand même encore
un certain nombre de mairies sur ce
réseau là tout n'est pas mort par
rapport à Renaissance qui n'a rien de ce
côté là donc on est en politique on
n'est jamais mort il se pose cette
question parce que dans l'opinion les
sympathisants ceux qui se disent
sympathisants socialistes aujourd'hui
alors on pourrait rappeler le score
évidemment famélique de Dani galgo à la
présentiel mais c'est ça pèse quoi
aujourd'hui 25% quand même on est entre
6 et 7 un ça varier un peu évidemment ce
qui est intéressant c'est de le mettre
en perspective avec ce qui s'est passé
il y a 10 ans donc élection François
Hollande ont été autour de 20% allez
entre 18 et 20 grosso modo et on a eu
cette questionnement qui s'est fait mais
petit à petit dès le quinquennat de
François Hollande parce qu'à la fin du
quinquennat on est plutôt autour des 15
16 et après l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron
on passe plutôt en dessous de la ligne
des 10 et puis sur tout au long du
premier quinquennat on est autour du 8 9
alliance nupes ou législatives 2022 et
désormais encore en dessous c'est à dire
plutôt autour de 6-7% des Français qui
quand on leur demande de quel parti
politique vous sentez le plus proche
nous disent le Parti socialiste est-ce
que ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui autour des retraites c'est à
dire le sentiment d'une partie de cette
gauche qui est manuel Macron ne peut pas
être un débouché politique pour eux et
définitivement qu'il faut se retourner
vers la famille politique historique
est-ce que ça ça peut constituer une
marche pour un renouveau ou un
redémarrage de ce socle du Parti
socialiste peut-être en tout cas nous le
on le suivra et puis alors bon on a
choisi on a terminé là-dessus Mathieu
souquier de centrer vraiment le débat
sur l'aspect on va dire le plus le plus
politique demain on parlera beaucoup
plus de des syndicats mais c'est d'abord
au syndicat que les Français font
confiance pour faire échouer ou modifier
cette réforme avant avant
qui que ce soit à la nuque oui alors
rappelons quand même que dans les
baromètres de confiance les syndicats se
situent assez bas et que désormais y
compris les grandes entreprises sont
significativement plus élevées mais
effectivement c'est quand même
intéressant contrairement au patronat au
syndicat patronaux les syndicats de
salariés ont vis-à-vis de l'opinion en
tout cas aux yeux de l'opinion une
légitimité à se saisir des grands débats
de société Emmanuel Macron disait au
début de son au début de son quinquennat
que les syndicats feraient mieux de
s'occuper de la situation des salariés
dans les entreprises et de faire un peu
moins de politique en réalité dans
l'opinion les syndicats sont considérés
comme légitimes précisément à faire de
la politique en tout cas à s'intéresser
aux grands débat de société et en
particulier à la défense du modèle
social et il ne fait pas de doute que
dans la bataille de l'opinion la
position de Laurent Berger qui est un
une figure considérée comme nuancée
responsable à la tête d'un syndicat qui
a toujours su se positionner la
responsabilité le discours très
vindicatif de Laurent Berger vis-à-vis
du gouvernement et de la Réforme pèsent
dans l'opinion merci beaucoup encore une
fois merci à tous les trois Matthieu
Suquet je rappelle le titre de votre
livre 2022 la flambée populiste coécrit
avec Damien floraux et publié aux
éditions
à bientôt sur ce plateau